now these filling in the dressing room
wait before you go out to walk the walk
to get in the ring well I'm just like
damn and the guy in front of me trying
to rip my head off he's trying to take
my kiss cheerios away from the kitchen
you know they're corn flakes I'm mostly
just thinking about them you know
because I don't want them to be
disappointed so I don't know they know
the day I just I fight for my kids and
my family destroy Slayer hey everybody
welcome to another very special episode
of hot box on big-time but you know what
it's not everyday know Andy Ruiz in the
house welcome brother champ of the world
heavyweight champ of the world
thanks man Wow title heavyweight champ
of the world you know it's pretty
amazing I'm just sitting here thinking
about I hang out with Mike all the time
and I feel so blessed to be able to
spend time with you Mike you won your
first belt 8686 so we've got the
heavyweight champion of the world of 86
and the heavyweight champion of the
world 2019
that's crazy it's pretty amazing yeah
man it's a big blessing you know my
tyson he's a big ass fan you know i've
been linking up since i was a young kid
and now to be here next to a champion
it's as beautiful but it's so beautiful
that you champ and you know underdog
nobody thought he was gonna do well you
know Ryan of a guy at the time that's
just really good just hoping it's just
beautiful to say thank you I know
beautiful from everybody underestimated
me telling me that I was going to lose
the way that I look you know being
chubby or whatnot but you know what
thanks to God I pulled it off and all
the hard work dedication that came
through and all the other supporting
that I have in
and all the Mexican fans I really
appreciate that you know what I known in
life and from fighting I learned him
from fighting you know like him fighting
their two fighters and the two people in
competition in general right and then
the statistics on who they are and what
they have accomplished and stuff but the
things under statistic you know they
took our way that he may be overweight
in pounds everything was left but they
see that but there's things under
statistic scale that that's invisible
that you don't see like perseverance
discipline determination you don't see
that that's invincible but those are key
qualities to success being tangible yes
yes yeah so key for any athlete or
competitor what does it mean to you man
like I mean growing up watching Mike how
old are you 29 29 so you were 89 89 wow
man I was 87 wow it's amazing dude so
you know growing up watching guys like
Mike I'm sure you were inspired by
Muhammad Ali and Joe Frazier and other
fighters as well watching those because
we grew up in that YouTube era where
YouTube came out and you could start
watch and all these guys fight from the
old days yeah so what does that mean to
you to now be you know you're not just a
guy looking out looking from the outside
in but you're part of that legacy now it
means a lot you know from making history
from becoming the first Mexican
heavyweight champion of the world it
it's a big blessing you know something I
uh you know I did something big from
Mexico and you know it's great I my name
is always gonna be there you know and
Ruiz jr. the first Mexican heavyweight
champion now nothing could take that
away from me you know so I thank God and
all the hard work you know I've been
waiting for this for all my life and now
you dare be more Mexican everybody can't
be yeah they're wrong look now you
showed them the way yeah big-time well
the thing is I'm just trying to show
people that everything's possible you
know everything is possible just working
hard believing in yourself and you know
just the stream training
what you want in life so it's possible
how many brothers and sisters you have I
have a younger brother Danny Reese's he
just turned actually 20 and my sister
Jessica she's 30 34 cool that's just me
it's just a little bit you know more
family yeah but I wanted a big family so
I have five kids so Wow amazing them
when did you start boxing since I was
six years old my dad took me to a gym
chubby little kid you know breaking
everything that's why they called me the
destroyer yeah um I had so much energy
my dad took me to a gym and I was six
years old my first amateur fight I was
seven years old and so then I just kept
training kept fighting doing a lot of
amateur stuff but my dad was he's always
been there for me you know if it wasn't
for him I I don't know where I would
have been at always pushing me looking
for me at my friend's house like Andy
you had a [ __ ] GO train what are you
doing that's beautiful um getting me in
trouble you know so he's always been
there
it's amazing then it's a lot of hours a
lot of time a lot of years
yeah not a disappointment during those
years yeah getting beat in the amateurs
not really think [ __ ] am I gonna be here
a champ or I can't beat this
[ __ ] yeah yeah you know it's
like doubting yourself absolutely no
what's the most difficult part of boxing
or anything in general when you first
start to keep that driving that fight um
regardless of what happened
disappointments during that time you get
beat you get knocked down you muscle you
might lose someone in your family things
happen things don't look little go your
way but you keep the persevering you
never give up and look what happened
yeah what was your mindset like going
into that fight for that photos I was
mentally focused for that fight you know
especially because April 20th that just
got done fighting and Alexander damnit
wrinkled it was my first fight on pbc
thanks to all Heyman in them and
um houses ready you know I'll set mode
and and after I took him out in the
fifth round I think he didn't want to
continue after that fight I kept saying
that I want to fight Anthony Joshua if
they don't have a fight or an opponent
hey I wanna I want to fight I'm I'm
ready I just got done fighting and I
message that he heard and what do you
know he messaged me back and we got it
done well good be exciting with you to
remit them yeah the rematch is that do
we have a date for that yet no day but
it should be sometime it's gonna be this
year probably in December but we're
still negotiating where it's gonna be at
Mike you defended your title nine times
yes Wow I'm not amazing man how was that
for you man having to defend the title
and keep coming back and keeping
yourself at that level remember um I was
all in my ego back then everything is my
ego back then you were just a monster
yeah it's what I do is just [ __ ] ego
I feel you sure you wanna fight yeah I'm
gonna [ __ ] you up yeah [ __ ] crazy
stuff yeah how about you Andy is that
what's your mindset like right now as
you get ready to defend that thing yeah
how do you feel about that how do you
filling in the dressing room way before
you go out to walk the walk to get in
the ring oh I'm just like damn and the
guy in front of me is he's trying to rip
my head off he's trying to take my kiss
cheerios away from the kitchen you know
the cornflakes I'm I'm mostly just
thinking about them you know because I
don't want to lose and I don't want them
to be disappointed so I don't know the
other day I just I fight for my kids and
my family and so honor God well your
friends think a kid's friends and school
say nothing that that I'm like a
superhero you know yeah especially to my
kids and
well at least they could say you know my
daddy could be your daddy up something
you know yeah there's a really happy man
who are the blessed and yeah I don't
know her man this small small kid out of
nowhere just what the big dream you know
and you grew up in Mexico I would have
trained over there almost okay so that's
why I represent me Kylie Baja California
and in Mexico so when I was young we're
always back and forth going over there
and but you know that's cool that's
amazing dude
so what after you won the belt man oh
Hellmuth what what that's great what's
your life become like what if what did
you manycam was the next thing what the
cameras like getting off the plane when
you were coming on shells crazy man but
you know I think that all comes with it
and it's just a big blessing you know
and like I said this is what I've been
waiting and dreaming about my whole life
and there's just a lot of happy people
you know everybody that came up big-time
everybody that comes up to me there
everyone's happy and but but it does
sometimes it gets annoying you know
everybody wants pictures it like you
know you can't keep everyone satisfied
you know because over there in my
hometown I was I think at Walmart or
something and I I was with my kids and I
couldn't take a picture with what the
person and I guess he got mad and he put
it on social media
oh you know that there's just like like
that
hey listen this is how I want to hear
your lesson
yeah how this guy's got the advice for
that it's the desire look at it right
take a picture with this guy in the sofa
you didn't have to see him no more no
more me thank you
you know I that's why he's making my
objective losers just the disarm
confrontation I take the picture for my
experience I know that people get that
way so I know for my experience he
hasn't been champ
really you know people get that way to
get their feelings involved because um
this is what they think this is what I
thought if he doesn't give me a
something's wrong with me it's not him
so I brought me my 30 my smelly my ugly
why do you want to take a picture with
me huh and my mind is me so there's
nothing him so I always know that could
be in his mind he might think it's him
in my defense always take a picture with
him my problem is real quick in this you
know yeah and what you have to
understand these people can they feel
like they own you because of the way
they did make you well so they have
their feeling that attachment to you
interested yeah but the end of the day
you know their hands exactly as like if
me or my daughter you know she saw
Justin Bieber or somebody my daughter's
I'm like wow but we never know what
happened okay post might and the family
was sick that day
mmm yes don't feel like okay I'm just
can't do it right now you know everybody
deal with life differently yeah yeah
well what about you know you're out
somewhere and you've got a crowd of
people mmm coming at you that's how it
is bro especially in my hometown you
know I can do is move on yeah I sign
moving and finance when I get in the car
love you know that I can't find before I
get out yeah but there's sometimes me
I'm trying to try to please everybody
and I'm like be trying to be the nice
guy you know yeah but but like I said
it's all big blessings and you know I
love my fans all my supporters and you
know I just can't wait for the rematch
true you know that I think that's what's
most important right now just to see
where young instead man those is crazy I
will [ __ ] my fans
[Laughter]
everybody's big pack them back for me
I'm looking at this in a naked picture
of your beloved yeah
Belov's mmm you can get paid so try to
be as normal as possible this you can
take your head to another place yeah we
have a family yeah my girl my girl [ __ ]
my mail I look and she sent me a nice
picture looking great I will call up
come over house on the ticket for you as
normal you know you were single dude
yeah I mean I can see kid you know new
better yeah that's crazy man you weren't
even 21 when you became yeah I can't
believe on my hair dude I wasn't happy
with Mike it feels good you know I I'm
just smiling the whole time not me after
this is god this is ordained by God I
didn't understand my life either and
stuff I mean but this is stronger for
thought he we call it God was a struggle
for that guys if we think we're shifting
and driving a car but we're not you know
what I do Jack's Mike you last week
aneema Guardian money juice that sounds
like your problem there I don't care go
on the bank okay put some money down and
win like a man the matter with you you
don't even listen to that [ __ ]
man going on right now
my bookie online [ __ ] it yeah [ __ ] him
only use my bookie online because I
think that [ __ ] from them
that's right my bookie online you play
you win they pay that's what I'm talking
about good all day every day
let's do it my bookie online boom my
bookies got the fastest payouts and
better lines than any other sports book
join now and my bookie will double your
first deposit just use promo code hotbox
and to activate the offer that's promo
code hotboxing and my bookie will double
your first deposit visit my bookie AG
today I mean for a big dude you've got
some [ __ ] fast hands brother how did
you develop that um I think my dad you
know my dad ever since I was young we
would always do mitts you know I think
that was my favorite thing when I was
little kid do a lot of a lot of MIT were
like a big bang yeah mm-hmm really like
yeah power yeah yeah you know and um in
ever since you know we just practiced
the speed a lot and but I think it's
just God's gift you know yeah he gave me
these the speed and me being begging all
that so yeah I kind of its your unique
composition yeah you do any speeches at
schools and stuff yet yeah I went over
there if you go over there my hometown
cool have you just been flying around
meeting people going to events shaking
hands kissing babies how do you do how
do you know how to take this [ __ ] yeah
how do you think this is now people want
you to come and essentially bless them
and bless like their lives you know I
mean you're that type of figure now
how's that that's crazy [ __ ] everybody
and it's crazy you know but how are you
processing that how are you dealing with
it you just are you just taking it
moment by moment do you have any
I'm just enjoying myself right now you
know yeah all the things that come to me
at least all the the positive stuff that
come to me I I receive it and we're just
enjoying life you know and especially
with my kids my family and buying I'm
just buying the stuff that I always
wanted you know and especially a my my
parents about my mom her dream car and
you know just in enjoying enjoying life
and so I have to start camp again and
then you have to make a statement again
what does camp start for you and of this
month you're coming up on it yeah it's
reading Cuban me names they might get
you ready to get in the front
yeah [ __ ] don't fight anybody
for me get a [ __ ] attitude yeah and if
anyone ago to cancer eighty kids brutal
them it's hard you know especially when
you have a lot of kids you know you got
to be away from them and be away from
the wifey and you know when you want to
[ __ ] she's no one's there or I don't
know is it's hard man I was a lot of man
in my training leave with my [ __ ]
makeup chill my man yeah training camp
in the NFL you'd have a conditioning
test the first day he got back yeah and
they'd see if you were in shape or not
like to doesn't know what this shit's
for get in shape get in shape
it's brutal though I'm guys like Walter
Payton he is baby sheep all year round
yeah yeah some guys are animal here just
incredible shape just machines man how
many boxers so huh I like the doing
thank you very much brother man I'm
proud of you man
you really did it and I was really
beautiful
I appreciate that crazy man
how many great men tried for that title
and never got it great fighters mmm oh
my god
millions of kids are dreaming of that
man it's possible you know it's possible
all the kids they have dreams is dream
big and just work hard you know like I
say his work hard and pray oh I'm
telling you I pray to God and for these
opportunities to come and but of course
I had to work hard you know I had to
work hard but my dreaming big and just
praying you know rain did you have any
times along the way where you were like
[ __ ] I don't know if I'm gonna make it
dirty worse you know there's there's a
lot of times when I already know yeah
die I'm not getting the results that you
want expect me Wow yeah I'm not that
good
mm-hmm how about any any fights you had
were you like [ __ ] I just got my ass
kicked
no you know what I've been her more
inspiring than in my real fights New
Jersey because I've got lazy and
sparring or something like that
I think mike has said that before yeah
guys used to boxing you stuff either
where yo your moves he maybe some days
he might kick you have to make you look
real bad yeah well I don't know where
there's always are good and bad days
yeah because I don't worry when we
retired [ __ ] we have to [ __ ] spar
again like I don't know I guess a little
tiring but as what we got to do yeah
what's the growth beating your ass to
and then this guy's farm partner being a
champion when he and they're beating
your ass yeah yeah so what are you doing
where do you live you live in LA I live
in Imperial Valley but I just bought a
house in Alpine California awesome man I
was like 20 minutes away from San Diego
good for you brother
mmm awesome so what are you doing what
are you doing right now before you're
getting ready to go to back to training
camp right now we're just enjoying this
good good interviews you know a good
people good
and I was with Joe Rogan I was Joe it
was cool man he's a really good guy
really a humble guy you got the cool
facility great facility you know yeah
here we're gonna get Joe definitely I
also go to this comedians show yesterday
but we didn't get to we didn't make it
in time who's I think Joe Rogan was
going to go on some comedian show mmm
you're in Hollywood
yeah there's a lot of those guys do you
go on clubs
now I didn't tell you that I don't
really go to play it's kind of I don't
like really being around where I can't
really he just yeah I'm a claustrophobic
I expect that all right I feel that too
man a lot of people get a little
squirrelly for me
what do you were in doing life and life
just I know I became a champion of the
world I want to defend it a lot of times
I want to fight sighs in fury but I like
in life after boxing or so my dad's a
contractor so we want to do is build
like an empire of construction and build
like a lot of houses over there in my
hometown so I have a lot of cousins
right here we got laid out right here
Fidel poem say he's a realtor and you
know he looks for lots and houses for me
so the house smell so silly yeah because
Baca never lasts forever doesn't when
it's over you're still young ain't that
some [ __ ] you're too old for boxing
but you just a baby in life yeah isn't
that crazy that is we I didn't
understand that that first retired yeah
how old are you and you were done I
don't know I might even 40 39 something
like that oh no no it's a long time 20
years
28 yeah Wow that's all I ever wanted to
do with the kid I saw I saw listen the
first time I ever saw I saw her burning
around for Sugar Ray Leonard in 1980 it
was June 20th right
I think that and I've never been to fame
my whole life it's just like take Emma
told mmm
my whole life changed I want to be like
these guys hmm and the RAM wanted to
fight so that was my hero
hmm I wanted to be like the Monday's to
go to restaurants we used to eat at I
had to read about and I would go then I
wait for my side just to see you yeah
shake his hand
yeah we're shooting it's like a god to
me yeah it's amazing though it's amazing
that lineage you know the process of how
we become who we are
no um I illusion of ourselves yeah
exactly
you know the van with a [ __ ] savage
of vicious [ __ ] whoa I was there
that turned me off
Wow my dick got a heart look I hand them
over
no we'll do the hand my fear [ __ ] yeah
yes bro it's amazing nice you have
anybody like that Andy um then I'd like
in boxing any heroes that just really
like lit that lit the fire in your soul
man of who you are and what you wanted
to be you know yeah it takes the water
talking so left foot that's what it was
yeah [ __ ] yeah I knew that this is my
life that's what I was gonna do I think
it's just all the fights that I've seen
you know especially of his of my Tyson's
fights and everybody else's but I don't
know I think it was just my drive of
wanting to prove everybody wrong and
that's strong and for myself you know
and you know I want people to look up to
me too and what did they like proving
people wrong how do you feel that must
be something right
you know the [ __ ] like look I [ __ ]
did it yeah everybody that was hating
but you know I still love the doubters
true you know that they're all fans yeah
okay and in a funny way
without them you might not have been so
motivated exactly you know if everybody
just loved you and thought you were
great and said yeah you're gonna be
champion man I mean that's good - that's
positive as well but you might not have
been so pissed off yeah - but you know
the kids I think they're the most
motivation absolutely right now other
ways I remember your family come first
anything secondary yeah mm-hmm cuz
identity when all this is over we gettin
old and green everything in life a
friend that we have here try that no
doubt about it man well brother it's
really an honor to have you near
beautiful thanks very beautiful and I've
been thinking for a long time that I
think it would be really beautiful it's
Mike got to meet you know the young
champions of this day of this time
because I think Mike thanks so much I'm
a long time ago yeah one time we met in
at the MGM and some really friends yeah
that's awesome a while back when I was
still recovering I faded myself
sometimes I found one how they feel in
yeah you know me and when I feel I see
the fighters when I said well honey feel
in there yeah it was they're hoping they
feel what felt like you felt yeah I feel
like I won he had to entertain the crowd
mmm
yeah it's amazing dude
I just thought I had to win you know I
had to win I go I was scared to lose you
know and and I don't know there's just
so many people depending on you
I said that's how I felt so many people
just depending on you and just that job
that [ __ ] I don't want to I don't want
to lose I don't want to lose but but I
think working hard you know working hard
and wanting to [ __ ] win you're gonna
win yeah again yeah with the work once
hit more yeah well you put the work in
something good is gonna happen
hmm you know like you said Mike the
harder you work the more luck finds you
yeah because the universe when you put
that energy into something the universe
starts to conspire to help you get far
angry hundred percent you know so it's
awesome brother we're can everybody find
you man
where can everybody follow The Andy
release story everybody could follow me
on IG on Andy underscore destroyer 13
thanks to all my fans all the supporters
we had 1 million followers so I never
thought that that was gonna happen you
know 1 million followers yeah pretty
awesome
it's amazing yeah I was really happy and
you know the that's where they could see
part of the my camp or what I do in life
you know how I'm enjoying my
championship you know it's awesome
well good luck to you as you defend that
big time thank you
keep rockin man keep grinding you know
never forget that that's where it
started man was all the hard work you
put in since you were six doesn't change
that part of it doesn't change so just
imagine that this is what you you
started six years ago your goal to be
the heavyweight champ you can't go no
higher than that yeah so when you get
there
your mind yeah we got to stay high and
just be smart you know I think that's
the main thing right now be smart be
smart with the money and be smart of the
people that you have around and you know
just live right that's it brother live
right
awesome middle Thank you Thank You Man
thank you say that Mike is a special one
yeah we had the chimp two heavyweight
champ in the world heavyweight champion
of the world Andy Ruiz everybody thank
you so much for watching this episode of
hot box and be sure to subscribe to our
YouTube channel hot boxing with Mike
Tyson until next time I'm Evan Britain
I'm Mike Tyson
I'm Mandy Ruiz junior heavyweight
janitors joy Andy the destroyer baby and
we're out of here ever love peace
[Music]